thank you all for joining us on this
webinar for those who don't know me my
name is Florian call I'm the manager of
the Y Quantum Institute and I'm the host
of the series of non-technical talks uh
co-sponsored by the Frankie program in
the science and the
humanities um the the idea of this
series was to uh talk about science not
in a scary way but by mixing other uh
topics uh like Humanities art design
music and and try to really engage on
these uh topics that are seen as
difficult but that we can really make
access accessible to everybody um so
this is the uh the 15th dog in this
series uh and we are delighted to have
uh clim Yankovich who is a designer and
uses her practice to design interface uh
without no code for quantum computers so
it's very exciting uh to have her uh
this this morning or this afternoon uh
currently in Israel um so Clen yovich uh
design and builds this interface but
before this uh she was working with
Museum Theater and other educational
institution to create uh exhibition and
uh interactive installation including
one on the the facad of the Poland one
of the most famous Museum in in Poland
um and uh and recently she has moved a
little bit on the field of quantum
physics uh working in collaboration with
physicists and uh and Engineers uh she
has worked with the center of cond
technology in Singapore aladu in Canada
Pascal in France and currently with
classic technology uh in in Israel and
and so the the idea for her was to build
all this interface and and of course she
will talk about this uh you know in a
few minutes uh but she has developed
among other some some game and
educational EXP experience like Quantum
flly trap pulso studio and virtual
Quantum lab and uh and so we have a lot
to talk about today uh and so we are
very excited to have you at yqi uh
virtually but hopefully uh at some point
uh on site thank you so much for joining
us
um um hi uh thank you for having me
Florian it's um I'm really um happy to
be here virtually um and yeah and uh and
um I'll talk today about uh mostly the
project I did in the quantum uh
industry uh and uh how I look at it and
uh what's important for me there my name
is CLM and I'm a designer and for the
last few years floran just mentioned
I've been working uh with the quantum
industry uh mainly building visual
graphical user interfaces to interact
with with the Quant Technologies uh and
this is what uh what I'll be talking uh
about today um and I'll start a bit
about user interfaces in general and how
I see this and what's important for me
uh and why I think uh building those
visual interfaces uh brings value uh and
then I'll show you a few examples of my
works so one will be pulser Studio we
buildt for Pascal uh I'll show you
Quantum flly trp lab uh um an
interactive Optical table which is an
educational tool and also show you a
sneak peek of something that we're
working on with classic which is not yet
released so uh it'll be only show a bit
of it only the design but uh hopefully
it'll be available quite soon uh and
also I'll show one uh one non-quantum
project but also it's something that I
think adds to this uh um uh conversation
about user
interfaces
um yeah so so user interface what is a
user interface um a space where
interaction between humans and machine
secure um so uh it's it's a way we
interact with the technology right so um
a language different interfaces are we
can think about it as different
languages have to interact and
participate in the technology uh and you
know of course there are many many
different uh interfaces starting with
what you see on your screen that's like
the most obvious one but also um of
course like a mouse or keyboard there
are uh voice
interfaces um there are interfaces based
on code or more visual ones uh like the
ones I'm uh I'm designing and uh um and
building um and we need all those
different kinds of interfaces because
they answer to uh different type Ty of
users they and uh different uh use cases
different uh situations so for example
uh a f fully visual
interface uh probably could be a bit
problematic when the vision is impaired
uh so anything from blindness to uh
looking at your phone in a full sun when
you can't really see anything right so
like different types of users but also
just different situation different use
case
um
and so those different types of
interfaces then they answer to those
different needs and essentially um by
choosing what type of interface we build
for a specific technology and how we
design this interface is a choice is a
decision of who can participate in the
technology um and this is something that
is very important for me uh especially
if we want uh
any it's not only Quantum any technology
to be inclusive I think it's it's
something to to really think about um
and when we do talk about Quantum
Computing um the most popular types of
interfaces uh are very text based um
this is um so it's usually either code
usually some kind of python library or
of course the uh scientific text um and
you know these are great interfaces
maybe scientific text aren't uh a
typical kind of interface but in this uh
in this situation it's I I do see it as
a um as a kind of interface because this
is it is a way to uh to understand the
technology or uh to participate in the
technology um so so these are of course
great right
so this particular example is uh from
Pascal because uh in a few slides I'll
show uh an example of a project of a
different interface with did for them so
so these are you know really really
great uh but they're not for everyone so
one obvious example would be if I don't
know python I cannot really use a python
interface uh and the same with
scientific texts um they they require
quite a substantial scientific knowledge
to uh to understand them
um and when we talk about uh Quantum
Computing a technology that you know can
potentially really at certain point uh
can impact everyone's life can change a
number of Industries uh then I think
there are a number of different uh use
cases and uh user groups that these
specific interfaces don't necessarily uh
aren't necessarily enough and one
example would be a public debate uh that
will be important or is already
important and we should have ways and
tools uh for a more general public to be
able to participate in this technology
of course
education uh this
is I think quite obvious we should lower
the the entry point uh we should make it
much easier uh for people to enter um
this uh this domain um but also
all sorts of business situation and this
is something that comes um that I hear a
lot with uh while working with the
quantum industry uh that you know this
is a very very complex technology uh and
sometimes there are certain situations
where maybe those uh non-physicists or
uh people are working with those uh
Technologies they do uh they would
require some more intuitive uh way to to
participate or understand or interact
with the technology um but I also think
there are many ways that it can be
valuable for for research um and even
for the most advanced uh
users and I will also talk about it uh
with the specific examples uh of the
interfaces uh I did um yeah so so I
think it's really really important to
try to think of a different ways that we
can produce different
interfaces uh different tools we can we
can build for uh for people to to access
this technology and to interact with
this technology um and the specific type
of interfaces that uh I build are the
visual interfaces the graphical user
interfaces or the no code or low code
interfaces uh and uh this is what I'll I
I'll show you now a few examples of
projects I I have worked
on so the first example I'll show uh is
um interface we built for uh for
Pascal uh so Pascal is a a startup from
Paris it was co-founded by Alana spec
the Nobel Prize winner from uh
2022 uh and we built for them this it's
like a visual and interactive
representation of their technology and
it's a no code uh development platform
for neutral atom Quantum
Computing and I'll go back to this uh
slide I just showed um a minute ago um
and so these are the main ways to uh to
interact with their technology to
understand the technology so they have
pulser a Pon library and of course a lot
of uh amazing research a lot of
scientific papers uh and again these are
great uh but they were looking for
another way to Showcase their technology
and another way to they were looking to
build another way for for the users to
be able to interact with their with
their technology uh and this is when we
um we uh we built the pulser Studio this
uh no Cod development platform online
platform um for Pascal and I see those
three types of those three interfaces is
just like different languages we can use
to interact with the same technology a
three different representation of the
same technology and they're all very
useful just in very different use cases
and for different users for different
situations okay so this is pulser Studio
it it's a bet of
version um so it's it's available online
uh anyone uh can enter it at puler
studio.
pascal.or of of their technology an
interactive representation of their
technology so the idea here was to go
very low level because it was they
really wanted it to be very specific for
their particular uh technology and the
research um so
um yeah and this is the the interface so
what happens here uh first of all uh we
have the register the an arrangement of
atoms uh and then when we when we
arrange our atoms in certain way uh we
can uh we build sequences of laser
pulses that are
um
um that um we sent to to spec to all of
the atoms or specific atoms um and it's
all very very interactive it's um can
move everything around we can uh
generate different patterns we want it
to be very very intuitive in something
that without any knowledge on building
the algorith people can uh can use as
well we have the codee panel here here
as well also to show what's Happening um
and yeah and these are these are the um
the light pulses we can uh easily change
everything add pulses uh and there is
also a simulation so uh if
um oh it's but uh if it's a smaller
number of atoms there is a simulation
online simulation uh available
um and we can see step by step what is
happening here uh which um
laser uh is being active when um so it's
yeah it's it's all very very uh
interactive and uh and intuitive and at
the same St we have different features
here um and at the same time we can see
what happens in the code uh we can Al by
highlighting certain elements we can uh
see how they are described and pulser
most important idea we had in mind when
designing this interface was to make it
really really intuitive uh because the
technology is very complex uh and then
we wanted the interface to not to add
any complexity to uh to this interaction
to leave all the complexity to the
actual uh technology uh and we want I
really wanted to to work in a way that
even if I don't know how to design a an
Quantum algorithm that makes sense like
what you now see on the screen obviously
this doesn't make sense from the quantum
perspective but you can still use the
you can still use the uh the interface
uh you can still easily play with it you
can still arrange the atoms uh you can
still make those channels with laser
pulses uh I we really really wanted it
to be super super intuitive uh and when
Pascal published the better version
there was someone who wrote a review and
I have a screenshot here because I
really like the way he described
it and he wrote that um pulser studio is
a fun for the whole family and um the
way I understood it is uh is that it's
something that can be used by the
professionals by Quantum algorith
designer but at the same time it's
something that this person can give to
their kid and the kid can play and just
make uh I don't know a smiley out of the
atoms and just you know play around with
the with the light pulses and arrange
them in different way uh and it's still
uh it's still playful and fun and for me
it really captures the idea what we
really wanted to to do with this project
[Music]
um and one way uh of working um one one
thing we did in the process of Designing
the interface to make it very intuitive
was to think about what
is familiar for what would be familiar
for the users and of course if we're
talking about visual graphical
interfaces for uh neutral atom Quantum
Computing there is no uh there are no
other tools so it's not like oh yeah
there are those 20 other tools and now
we can only think about how to make it
better there we we didn't have a road
map here so we're looking at other
solutions from uh different Industries
and different areas and for example for
the for the channels with uh laser
pulses we looked at uh all sorts of
software for uh editing music and making
music so or mostly editing music uh or
editing sound uh and of course the use
case is very very different right right
because you know here it's we're editing
sound and here we're designing a Quantum
algorithm but in the end of the day
these are some Channels with a certain
timeline and with those wave forums that
the users can move around can change can
edit uh so we to make it intuitive we
try to learn as much as possible from
those different kind of softwares but
that are so well research and there are
so many examples what works best there
um and so this was one of the one of the
things we tried to
do in this project um and also the
simulation so uh with those the smaller
setups uh it's an automatic simulation
up to six atoms and uh it's possible
also to simulate uh setups up to 12
atoms um and uh there was when we were
user testing uh the the solution one of
the physicists one of the uh devel the
people who develop Pascal's technology
so one of the people who know about it
the most uh this person told us that I
don't even have to think what happens
physics wise I can just follow what's on
the screen uh and I really liked it
because um it was quite obvious for us
this is that this will be good for the
business cases it'll be great for for
education but then I was really happy
that it Al also valuable for their own
internal uh research um research team so
the people that know the most in the
world about Pascal's uh technology uh
and I know that they still use it and
that a lot of uh aot a lot of the
physicists and engineers in the Pascal's
team they they still they still use
it um
and um and this is also like a very very
small
example um of very basic example of how
it can be uh useful in this uh
R&D uh like for an R&D use case so a
research use case or development use
case um and
um um and you can see on the left side
the register uh the six six atoms six
cubits uh and on the left side you see
the code
uh and when we highlight the uh the
atoms we can see where they actually are
in the code uh and when look at it it's
quite obvious that you know to to
arrange the atoms in this way it's it's
very intuitive it's very simple to do it
in this very graphical visual way uh but
to do it in code it's it just not the
right tool it sounds uh it's something
that's that's quite obvious um and
of course there are many different ways
the the researchers use it but I think
this this specific one shows uh in this
minimum like a very small example of how
how it how it is useful for uh for the
researchers um and of course uh you know
from the beginning when we were
developing this um this solution this
business case was very important for us
so the all the business situations uh
and this is just so much more efficient
so so much it's much easier uh to
showcase the technology when uh the the
business people on Pascal side but also
the client side when they have something
that is interactive that is visual that
doesn't require you know two months of
of studying of how to uh how to use
something um and so this was from the
beginning very very important uh point
for us uh how to show how to make this
interface that it's it's very intuitive
it shows the technology instantly but at
the same it's it's a real thing um for
now if you if you go to to the website
it's still not connected to Pascal's qpu
but the moment they release the QPS to
public it'll be connected so uh so
anyone will be able to um to execute uh
an algorithm built in pulser Studio on
their actual Quantum
Hardware um and now I'll show you
another
project uh and so this is the quuly Trap
Virtual Lab uh it's um an
interactive uh also available online
interactive
uh Optical table uh so kind of a Sandbox
where users can drag and drop elements
and make experiments or recreate
experiments and this project started at
cqt in Singapore um over four years ago
um and we went there where a group of
people work with physicists and software
Engineers um and we worked uh on a uh on
a game or a computer game about quantum
physics um and later we continued the
project and it became the quantum flight
trap projects and with decided decided
to go more into the direction um of an
of an educational tool rather than a
game uh it's it's free to use for anyone
and I know that a lot of uh Educators
around the world are using it uh from
high school uh High School teachers uh
there's number of uh online courses that
uh use the Tool uh during the during the
courses uh but also for at ities for
example uh the Oxford University they're
U they're using it at Quantum
information course um yeah so so it's
this is this one is mainly educational
this was always the the main uh idea
here um and I'll show now the uh the
platform
itself so we have this
um this board this is the this virtual
Optical table uh where we can uh drag
and drop elements uh and start like here
uh and uh we can edit all of the
[Music]
elements uh to create whatever
experiment uh we'd like to see um and
um there is uh we have uh up to we have
a simulation
uh so it's a um it's the same uh the
same simulation we used for the project
uh for Pascal for pool surf studio uh so
it's not only you know a playful
colorful visualization but it's also
like all the math is there uh so users
can see what happens uh step by step uh
and we have different uh features that
users can use to to learn more about
what's happening um on the screen uh and
we have up to four entangled
photons
um and um we have a number of Saved
experiments um for because again this is
an educational tool so this is uh people
can look at different famous experiments
uh and see how to uh recreate them in
our uh in our lab go back to the
presentation
now um and the idea and inspiration is
quite obvious here of course it's it's a
visual it's an interactive online
representation and simulation of optical
table uh and of course we looked a lot
about on how uh these experiments are
represented in the uh scientific uh
literature uh so uh this is of course of
course Very uh in a way very similar
which just made it
um
interactive um and maybe also a bit more
playful and the project as I said uh at
the beginning the project started as a
game uh and later evolved into this more
educational uh experience uh and at
certain point we're thinking about
changing the the interface this
graphical layer to something a bit more
uh serious uh but
uh we talked with the users and we found
out that
actually majority of people like the
fact that it was all colorful and
playful maybe because it's educational
so it's probably students and and young
young people that uh like games so we
decided to stay to stay with this uh gy
feeling gy look um and one thing I
really liked and uh I think it was very
valuable from the beginning with this
project was that we were developing it
um very closely with our users um so on
one hand because it's free to use for
everyone so there was just a lot of
people uh sending us messages emails we
have a Discord channel so talking to us
and telling us their ideas and what they
would like to see there also what
doesn't work if we had some bugs that
was also very uh very useful um but we
were also uh asking other researchers
and uh scien physicists to to tell us
what they would like to see there what
do they think would be great to uh to
have what features what elements uh what
kind of experiments they would like to
see uh and for
example uh someone told us that it would
be great to um to see um the eler viman
bomb test the the the thought experiment
uh so we were like okay great uh well we
had a bomb already so we had to do some
Chang
uh to be able to uh to add this um to
add this experiment uh but we did it and
uh and then my colleague actually talked
with the Le vidman uh and he showed him
the the experiment and I don't think he
he was he had a lot of feedback he
didn't immediately under understand
everything that was happening there so
it was obviously very very important
feedback for us uh and we tried to
encorp orates as much of his of his
feedback as possible um but we also ask
him about some other things he would
like to see there and what could be uh
simulated there and for example he
mentioned oh it would be great to have
uh IND indistinguishable particles for
two Photon interference or the GHz
entangled state so we were like okay
great let's do it uh and we added these
and and this was from the beginning uh
this was the process we were asking
people and of course you know not we
weren't incorporating every single
feedback but from the beginning this
process was very very natural and uh we
were just okay trying to listen and like
okay let let let's do it uh it this
sounds great
um and you know as I said of course the
main usage was educational and a lot of
Educators uh used and still use uh this
tool and we had a really nice um situ
ation that I will talk about now um with
a much older version it was few years
ago so it was much much older much
simpler version uh of the lab uh it was
just the beginning of the pandemic uh
and uh a professor from Stanford reached
out to us uh she found the uh she found
the tool online and she reached out and
she said that uh she usually has those
Hands-On experimental classes but now
the pandemic started and um everything
moved online and suddenly she was left
with a textbook uh so she was looking
for something uh a bit more interactive
a bit more uh fun for the student and
she found our project and uh and then of
course she and the students they gave us
a lot of feedback and this was really
great and uh we made a lot of changes uh
according to their feedback and at the
end she told us that even when it
becomes possible to teach my class in
person again your website your project
could help me scale to a larger class
size than is possible when I require
equipment for Hands-On
demonstrations um and I really really
liked what she said because uh this is
in a way it's it's really talks about
what what I said in the beginning so of
course this interface this is not
instead of the actual lab right uh but
it's it's a different different way to
interact with it uh and it's a different
way to learn about it so this professor
should still have this experimental this
Hands-On class uh but she could use this
tool to make a class to a much larger
group of students um and for me this is
the main reason to build those visual
interfaces not to exchange a different
type of interface but to open um this
technology to some new situations new
use cases and new
users and now I will show uh a third
project uh third Quantum project and
this is uh it it's just a sneak peek I
can't show uh the full project yet it's
not released we're still working on it
uh so I'll only show a bit of the design
um and this is something uh we're
working on with classic classic is an
Israeli startup uh based in Tel Aviv
uh and we're working on on this kind of
uh visual graphical interface graphical
user interface uh for the classic
platform and just to give you a bit of
context um so this will be part of of a
much broader product so it's it's not uh
it's only a part of the of the of of
Classic's product uh and the classic
platform um allows user to design um to
build to design a model uh that can be
later synthesized uh into a Quantum
circuit that is optimized in certain way
depending on the use case uh depending
on the needs uh and later users can
execute uh the circuit on uh any of the
available Quantum backends so Quantum uh
simulators and and actual Quantum
Hardware on in all in one platform uh
and the project I'm showing will'll be
part of this uh first uh First Step so
building the model uh building the
functional model the the the
algorithm and as I showed you on this
slide it's we're building this kind of
node
interface um
and and this again comes to this
question about how to make it as
intuitive as possible and how can we
learn from other solutions from
different Industries different uh use
cases but how can we learn from them
from things that that are researched
really well there are a lot of different
uh products and how how can we learn
from there and build something for for
Quantum uh and we decided to use this
kind of node
interface uh and um on the one hand um
the uh things we we researched and we
looked at so one hand it will this whole
world of electronic circuits schematics
net lists it's maybe not the most user
friendly but uh but there's a lot of
important Solutions there that are very
very relevant for uh building Quantum
algorithms um and of course more typical
uh node interfaces uh for example for 3D
modeling like blender uh there's some
music software there's a lot of
automation software so there are quite a
lot of different solutions um that were
developed for for very different
Industries uh and we're trying to learn
from them and see how can we translate
it uh for uh into
Quantum and it's um we try I hope it'll
be very simple uh so the users will just
choose
um uh blocks either functions or or
Gates um or they can create their own
blocks and they just wire them uh
together and uh they can add more and
more blocks and wire them and build the
algorithm in this very very visual
way uh they can merge them uh if they
have a lot of small blogs they can merge
them into bigger blogs they can uh build
uh their own blocks from scratch uh and
um
I think it'll be also really good uh for
adding external data uh this is also
something that comes back when I'm
talking with users and especially uh
users from different domains so someone
from Finance maybe they would just like
to have this some kind of Finance block
where they only upload their CSV or some
other format of the data be also really
great for all sorts of visualizations
that's very natural language here um and
of course we still um we're still it's
it's still not released so uh the use
cases it's only something that uh um we
think of and uh and uh I hope to learn
about different use cases when we when
we do release it uh but some of the
situations where I think it could be
useful uh would be like for example uh
for uh maybe domain experts like I said
about uh uh about uh finance and um and
people that they might not maybe they
don't want to work in code so much it
might be easier to for them to work with
something visual uh but also I hope
it'll be useful for researchers so I can
imagine the situation that someone uh is
working on their research they're
publishing the research and then they
can have this
interactive
um Interactive visualization of of their
research interactive representation of
their research that anyone can uh can
play with can interact with uh and can
maybe build upon in in a very intuitive
way uh and of course for learning uh
again all the visual Solutions I think
this is uh this is something that is
really a no-brainer for learning um
and I can imagine someone opening an
example of an algorithm and then looking
inside and seeing what are the different
building blocks of this algorithm uh and
trying to build their own way their
their own algorithm so I think this this
for sure will be uh really valuable for
them um and again this is just a sneak
peek this is just a uh a design so but I
hope that it'll be uh some first version
will be available soon so uh stay uh
yeah you can uh uh check the the
platform uh uh to to see um hopefully
soon it will be uh will be released um
and the last project I wanted to show
you is something very very
different um
and and it's in a way comes back to this
idea of different users and different
situation and producing very different
or researching very different types of
um of interace faces h of ways we can
interact with
technology uh and this is a project I
did a few years ago it was an art
installation for a theater play about um
the human technology
interaction um and it we buil this I
designed um this uh swarm of uh
electronic objects I designed objects
and the electronic part uh and those
objects were were placed around the
actors uh and were also some kind of an
actor in a way um and the interaction
was happening so the kind of the
interface was a it was a voice interface
so the the actors would interact with
this installation uh with their voice uh
and the installation would uh reply with
with voice and with sound and uh with
light and would change depending on how
the actors interacted with it
um
and this is you know when we think about
this it's a very different use case and
a very different uh user type than uh
than physicist for example uh but uh
when we think actors on on the stage of
course having an interface where they
click somewhere on the screen with a
mouse that that wouldn't be suitable
that would probably be uh very boring
and uh and just not not something they
needed uh and of course this is in a way
exaggerated but I wanted to show it um
that it we should really think about
interfaces uh as all the different ways
we can interact with technology and that
each different type of inter
interface um refers to a different or
answers to the needs of a different
group of users or a different situation
A use case uh for example physicist or
or actors um yeah and these are the the
four projects uh I wanted to show you
today so thank you very much thank you
so much for such a great talk thank you
for sharing with us all your all your
project uh the first thing that when we
see all of these project and especially
interface we see lot of purple and I
have a question about this because also
at at yqi some of the work that been
doing like most of the quantum is
becoming purple like it's it's shifting
towards this color I was wondering
what's why did you pick this color is it
because it's more of a dark system or
like is it do you have a meaning behind
it like what's why did you pick this but
by my
first yeah that you know that it's funny
because when I put all of them together
I also thought that it's very very
purple um it was something that
um it was very intentional with quantum
flly trap and I really uh researched at
the beginning what are the colors that
kind of sorry make people think about
Quantum things uh and I was very happy
to uh to find out that it was this like
purple sometimes like yellow pink uh but
I think it's um it's prob a mix of of
you know what what works well um and and
what I personally like it's always
somewhere somewhere in between um so um
and these are all uh just like dark
background interfaces um which um I
think this mainly comes from the fact
that uh you know with each project this
would be always a discussion and we
would think that okay with uh with the
users we have with mind usually people
tend to uh choose the the dark mode uh
that's but yeah that's uh
the yeah that there is a lot of uh uh
definitely but that's why you know it's
like a first stage then ideally there
should be uh the light mode added as
well um but also for sure something that
uh I do like a strong color uh it is
yeah it is very to be used very
beautiful yeah uh the uh the reason why
we're using purple a lot is because on
the BL sphere you have like the one and
zero and then like it's a mix of usually
physicist use red and blue and so to
sort of like hint at the supervision of
States it's nice to have this like
purplish thing that comes in so like it
it was interesting to to see even if
it's not the main the main thing um
another question that I have and and for
people in the audience if you're at yqi
feel free to unmute the room if you want
to talk or you can use the Q&A feature
at the bottom of the screen to ask your
questions um one question I have is that
how did you jump from doing installation
and education soltion to Quantum like
Quantum is is seen as often scary like
what was your what was your process and
like how much did you know before going
to Quantum uh work on this because I
think to create very valuable interface
you need to have a good understanding of
what's happening on the in the
technology to be able to recreate and
simplify it without over oversimplifying
it to for the
audience um yeah so um I started at cqt
this was like literally the the first
time uh uh I started to learn anything
about Quantum Technologies um and um you
know it started uh a year earlier uh I
was participating in this project uh um
made by by uh run by MIT media lab in
Berlin they had did this like European
uh short uh like onewe project and
invited uh all sorts of uh people from
from Europe to participate also about
this uh Crossroads for of technology and
design music art um and I you know and
there was one person there who was a
Quantum physicist and then somehow we
stayed in touch and a year later he was
I saw that he's looking for people to uh
to come with him uh to build a game
about quantum physics at cqt and I
thought oh that's that's perfect uh what
what could go wrong uh so it it
literally started like this this wasn't
intentional and I thought it'll be uh
you know a fun weird project I'll have
in my CV and I and then you know I
started working on this and I started
working with a lot of physicists uh and
I thought wow this is the most uh this
is the most interesting and most amazing
thing you can imagine um and I thought
okay that's what I want to do I want to
stay in in this uh in this industry uh
but of course all of these projects you
know it's these aren't only my projects
there was always a team of developers
and physicists so it's uh I I wouldn't
be able even to do the design it's it's
a collaboration of of the whole team and
it's everyone's ideas so so there was
you know a lot of physicists uh involved
here um and with the time I of course
know more and more but I'm still not a
physicist yeah but that's I think that's
that's the beauty of of working at the
interface of Science and Technology and
and arts and amenities that like you
really need to bring people from
multiple skills because while a
physicist can be really good at
explaining the technology itself or
building the technology they might not
be necessarily good at doing interface
and like helping convey ideas on on on
the graphical level so like I think
that's that's really a brilliant uh move
on on all of this interface you also
talked about fact that um you are using
software techn technique that people are
used to for example like the same way
that we have still the little save icon
icon being a floppy disc in the corner
of your screen while we don't use floppy
disc anymore it's interesting that
you're going back to how we make music
how we make uh like blender nodes and
things like can you talk a little bit
more about why are we always looking
like why are we always using for
interface stuff that reminds us of of of
the past for like the objects outside of
the virtual similar to how the notpad in
on on software used to be a physical not
pad and they tend to be yellow the same
way that the paper used to be like that
kind of that kind of thing what's what's
the reason behind it and and how can you
use that to your advantage uh for for
the design of interface people who don't
know necessarily the
technology um yeah so I think first of
all it doesn't need to be like this and
I think there are many uh cases when the
in we want to you know when you think
about something for example very simple
maybe some kind of a website when you
know designers try to be sometimes uh
you know go crazy with the interface and
and the whole idea is about doing
something very unusual very different so
it really depends on the use case it
doesn't need to be like this but in the
case of quantum I think the technology
itself is so complex that I always think
that I don't want to add to this
complexity uh by an interface that is
hard to understand and that's why um I
try to design interfaces that are
intuitive that they're very you you know
users immediately know what to do or
it's a you know if they need to learn a
bit it's it's it's very little and to to
leave this time of learning to to learn
about the technology and not the
interface itself uh and then of course
uh you know we all use interfaces all
the time so uh this by using the
interfaces we'll learn uh about how this
world works so then using certain um
solutions from from other industries
from other totally different areas it's
just something that it's something we
know it's just something we've learned
already uh so it's very intuitive for
for the users to to um yeah to use the
same uh um to behave in the same way
when they see this interface even though
it's Quantum and not music uh but we see
this uh this channel so it'll be very
intuitive to know oh okay I can probably
swap or I can do this or
that um and when you when you play
testing this this application or like
education uh do you because here on on
the on the call right now we have a lot
of people who have uh shared like mixed
experience some have not at all
understanding of quantum some have a
little some work in quantum physics and
and so when you've tested with all these
people um is there uh when you have
somebody who doesn't know anything about
quantum physics playing on this platform
how does it impact the fact like the the
interface and and your work then if you
have that person on the platform and
also a very qualified person who knows a
lot like how do you work uh to make sure
that the platform is available for both
type of of users because I think it's
it's a bit of a challenge to have
something that is robust complex but
still making it available for people who
don't know anything like if they want to
you've been writing 2023 I think that
was for your New Year's Eve celebration
I've seen online a couple of like
Christmas tree and and stuff like this
like really fun interface um but like so
to engage the the audience that doesn't
know much about Quantum uh like how do
you convey these two type like how do
you create interface for these two type
of of
users um so I think there's this one uh
idea that I really like um that uh I
think it was
um Professor Mitch Resnik who built
there's this software for children to
scratch to to learn programming uh this
like visual uh way of how children can
program their own games or or all sorts
of things uh and he wrote a book about
uh building software and there's this
really nice idea uh there that uh that I
I think a lot about a lot when I'm
designing the interfaces it's about
making uh low floors High ceilings and
wide walls um so it should be very easy
to start uh but at the same time it
should give uh users uh a lot of space
to continue uh Beyond this like very
basic examples very basic things to make
so for example we have the simulation in
the lab right so uh if I'm not a
physicist I won't use it because like I
don't really understand it or maybe I
can use it and learn this way but uh but
it but it's there and for the the more
advanced users it gives them this
additional uh way to to use it uh and
also ideally tomato those white wall so
to to give possibility to to different
to for users to go with this into
different directions to make their own
things so it's not only to recreate what
what we did but you know also to learn
from them uh like we did in with P of
flly trap that uh it was like I said
about the development that we would
always listen to the users and add new
features or new new um uh new uh new
elements uh when they were telling us
that uh oh I have this interesting uh
use case in mind so um but I also have a
kid who's she's seven now and uh so I
always show her what I work on and uh
she's she's also testing
so Studio
was like okay if she can arrange the
that's that's good that's that's a good
thing yeah uh also um I uh I like the
fact that you you also work with theater
um I have a theater background so I used
to be an actor when I was younger and
and switch to science later on is there
a way like I've always wanted to bring
the into Quantum I know it's going to be
very difficult but is there a way like
can you imagine a way of of bringing
that type of Arts into the work of
quantum uh which could be like I think
really challenging in because we're
talking about very different things but
like since you're mixing technology and
and and Theater here like could we could
we imagine a
pulsar integration for example on to a
play or something like this what's your
what could be your like it's a tough
it's not even a question but it's tough
uh like that's really domain that I
would be interested in uh going into
yeah I mean you know I I would love to
see something like this or work on
something like this uh I definitely
really love the projects that go out of
this realm of only you know things that
happen on the screen or or like at least
the this user layer is on the screen so
I definitely really like all sorts of
installations and uh uh and uh building
and designing those um experiences uh in
space uh yeah so I think there's
definitely a lot of uh a lot of uh space
here for for some experimentation and it
reminds me of uh um when when I was in
Singapore uh it was the beginning uh of
uh of my um uh of me working with the
quantum industry and of course as I said
I didn't really know anything uh or too
much about physics then like probably
you
know level that I also forgot a bit by
then and I remember that a colleague uh
she's a Quantum physicist she was
explaining at certain point uh it was
something about uh light waves and and
uh
um and she was showing different kind of
uh um waves with her like she did like
this whole dance and she was moving like
she was pretending to be the wave so so
probably there you know there is a lot
of space for thinking about something
creative here fascinating well thank you
so much for uh taking the time to
talking to us about all these project uh
it has been really a treat um for people
there was like the yearl on every
project so I will invite you to go
online and test all of this interface
we'll keep an eye on the on the classic
uh interface uh to soon be able to to
play with it uh thank you very much for
your time and uh we hope to see you at
another W technical BL event soon thank
you so much thank you for inviting me my
pleasure